[Applause]
>> Randall Macon: I'm kind of a nervous presenter
so I tend to walk around a lot. So I apologize
if it gets distracting. Am I on? Sounds like
it. [adjusting mic] How's that? Is that better?
Oh, there we go. Excellent. How are you guys
doing?
>> Audience: Good.
>> Randall: Excellent. I got my clicker thing
here. So I was working on this presentation.
It was actually an interesting little exercise
for me. I was telling Dave that the program
that we have -- one of the exercises is you
have to give a life giving speech. And so
I said, you know, what? I need to eat my little
dog food a little bit if I'm going to be the
CEO of this organization. I should start doing
some of the exercises I'm expecting our customers
to do. And so, this is what I'll refer to
as a minimum viable presentation. If it's
a little bit bumpy. If it doesn't completely
click, then you guys can ask me questions
at the end and we'll fill in gaps. The thing
I wanted to talk about today is a question
that's really core to a lot of what we focus
on with the company and also a lot of what's
important to me. And it's a really simple
question. And it seems like, "Hey, I can answer
that question." What do I really want? And
it's interesting. What I'm gonna do is use
my story, my journey what I've gone through
as a bit of a framework to think about what
is it you really want. And hopefully this
is an opportunity for you to be thinking about
that in a different way. And thinking about
that in a way that will get you further than
where you are whether it's here at Google
or some place else. I think as part of the
invitation there's also a optional exercise
that's called eulogy and epitaph. How many
of you guys got a chance to read that. One,
two. Okay, you guys get called on just so
you know. [laughter] So let's start out with
this interesting quote. It says "as for those
considering taking the time some day to plan
their final weeks and months, three words
of advice, Move it up." Now this was a gentleman
-- anybody recognize that quote first of all?
Sound familiar? It's a guy named Eugene O'Kelly.
Ringing any bells yet? No, not yet? Well,
he's actually the CEO of KPMG. Was at KPMG
for 30 years. And is an award winning author.
And why that is a compelling statement or
quote is that he actually wrote that in a
book called Chasing Daylight. He found out
he had basically three months to live. Had
brain cancer. And he wrote a book about what
it was that was really important. And so,
what I wanted as we go through this, I want
to try and give that same kind of context.
Because what's really powerful for him, yet
at the same time really unfortunate for him
was, he gained a lot of clarity and focus
and a real sense of urgency at the end of
his life. And it was interesting -- I was
reading an article about Steve Jobs' book
just came out. And he was -- the person who
wrote it said that the reason that Steve Jobs
wanted to write the book was because he wanted
to tell his children why he wasn't there.
And that becomes a really -- for me becomes
a really poignant question. Because I have
a two and a five-year-old. And it's also really
important because are you going to wait till
the last 100 days and look at it and say,
"okay. Now I'm going to cram everything that
I really wanted into that last 100 days? Or
are you going to start doing things now that
will empower you to think about what it is
you really want. So when I was graduated from
college in 93. So I was getting the tour from
Veronica and she was walking around talking
about old school music. I [chuckles] was kind
of sad to realize I'm now old school. [laughter]
Slightly depressing. But I try to get my street
cred up by naming rappers that were a little
unknown. Guru. Anyone a Guru fan? Nice. Nice.
It's how my wife and I met actually. But it's
interesting. When I got out of college, I
wasn't really sure what it was that I wanted.
But it was a lot about me. And so, what I
thought that I wanted -- it's not me. This
is actually a friend of mine. A really close
friend of mine. John Sore and Mack Dog. Probably
one of my best friends in the world. We lived
together for awhile. We were rock climbers
and we had a really amazing time going on
trips together. Rock climbers? Yes. You all
get called on, too. But at that point when
I was asking that question what do I really
want? What I wanted was to go hang out with
John and Mack Dog. I wanted to go climbing.
I wanted to figure out how I could have more
fun in my life. And so, I was part-time rock
climber and part-time start up guy. Not starting
things up but working in startups because
apparently those were the only people who
were going to let let me go rock climb part-time
and get paid some amount of money. And when
I say startup, keep in mind at that time it
was a dial up, start up. We were offering
14.4 dial up service when you could actually
do that. It was weird. But that was a part
of my life that was -- it was really important
to me. John, as amazing as he is, he moved
away. He moved to Seattle and ultimately to
New Zealand. And he's doing amazing things
at Weta Studios where he's doing animation
design for King Kong and I, Robot and doing
amazing things. And I had to ask myself that
question again, "what is it that I really
want?" And I had to reevaluate that. And at
that time, my now wife and girlfriend, we
were thinking about it and we were saying,
"okay, what is it we want?" Our friends, the
lifestyle we thought we were building is not
there anymore. So how do we go about figuring
that out again. And so, at that time, that
was in the late 90s. I was like, "I have an
idea." I've been in start-ups. I'm going to
find a start up and I'm going to get some
of that IPO money. I'm gonna figure that out.
My plan was get rich and go rock climbing.
That was my grand plan. Very, very thorough,
deep thought -- thinking that I was doing.
At that moment in time. And I had actually
planned it all out. I was going to find a
company. They were actually going to build
a company that their whole exit strategy was
they were going to get bought out by somebody
really soon so I only had to work really hard
for a couple years then I'd get some of that
IPO money. Well, that didn't really work out.
I did end up working for an Internet consultancy
that I won't name. And I kind of had an IPO.
It's more in the form of a severance package
and they asked me to leave. [laughter] But
I got a little bit of money. It wasn't anything
I was going to retire on. Kind of made me
pause and say hey I got a little opportunity
and a little space. What is it I really want?
That question over and over. You emphasize
each word differently. You say "what do you
really want? What do I really want? What do
I really want? What do I really want?" Start
flipping those phrases over and over and it
starts meaning something different, depending
on where you are in your life. But, if you
don't start asking yourself that question,
then it becomes very difficult to even get
on track. And what I find myself doing even
at this point, I'm just kind of meandering.
I thought I was going to be climbing a lot.
I thought, at this point, I'd have all the
money I needed; wanted. I wouldn't have to
worry about it. It wasn't what I really wanted.
About that time, after I was offered my own
personal IPO, the severance package, the Lance
Armstrong Foundation was in its early stages
and there I think ten employees at the Lance
Armstrong Foundation. It was out of a house.
I happen to know was introduced because some
of the board members of the Internet consultancy
I was at were also board members on the Lance
Armstrong Foundation. So I had a bit of an
"in." And it was also the topic of cancer
was something that was pretty important for
me and my family. Because my mother-in-law
had been -- is is a cancer survivor. She had
breast cancer; last year had bladder cancer.
Hopefully when I -- I didn't tell her I was
going to do this so hopefully when she sees
this on YouTube, she won't be too annoyed
with me. But she's an amazing woman and she
does some amazing things. She's very much
an inspiration for me. So cancer was important
not only because of her but my grandfather,
my grandmother, my aunt, all passed away because
of cancer. And so, this was like, "hey", that
question, "what do I really want?" It's like
I want to make an impact. I want to have an
opportunity to e able to impact people's lives.
And so, I think that was a really a big part
of what was motivating. It was motivating
me to say, "what is it that I can do that's
going to have an impact?" Didn't have a lot
of clarity around that. Didn't really have
a lot of urgency. And the thing that happened
with LiveStrong, even though we put a lot
of effort into it, it was something that was
really meaningful. At the end of the day,
I did a quick search on Google images and
this is what I found when I typed in LiveStrong.
And at first it kind of made me sad, because
I was looking at it and it was like, "you
know, it's awesome that they raised all this
money. They have this amazing database of
millions of potential people who can be advocates
on their behalf. And it started and I was
like, "man, was all that just about merchandising?
Did I just kind of throw myself at something
just so I could say that I was a participant
in something like that?" Then I started kind
of digging through my own files and also digging
online a little bit and I couldn't find this
image, but I did find this particular image
which, there's a story that goes with this
that's pretty powerful. Not this guy in particular,
but what -- in the early days of when we were
selling wristbands and it got really crazy
where we were selling 100,000 wristbands.
It seemed like we were paying more attention
to whether or not we could get OS Commerce
to actually handle the load or whether or
not it was about the people who we were supposedly
doing this for. And this guy sent in a picture.
And he, in these gang Gothic letters, put
LiveStrong across his back. Similar to what
this guy did. And it made me stop and I was
like, "that's why I did it." I did it because
this gives somebody an opportunity to express
a perspective that they have and allows them
to connect. There's another interesting story
that at, one point I was -- this was back
in like 2004 -- I was at an airport and very
few people knew what the yellow wristband
was. And quite honestly we were looking at
it and going -- Nike had come to us and said,
"we're going to make these 5 million wristbands
and sell them." And we're like, "Sure, that
seemed like a ridiculous idea." But when I
was in an airport, there were two people in
that airport who were wearing wristbands who
didn't know each other. Then they came and
started talking to one another. Then they
started sharing their own stories. They provided
that opportunity for connection. And that
to me was like, "that's something that I really
want. I want to see something like that. I
want to have that ability to affect that kind
of change." Not necessarily change but affect
that kind of relationship and connection in
people's lives. And that worked out for awhile.
But then I kind of got antsy. Tell my wife.
She agrees. We go on these two year cycles
where it's like" hey yeah this is great" to
"not satisfied". Gotta kind of figure it out.
Had to ask that question again what is it
that I really want? Well, by this time I had
had my daughter, Lila, who my father refers
to as Lila the amazing. And my son who is
the antithesis. His name is Boon. But he refuses
to use only Boon and he's just Boon Macon.
And my favorite story -- this is actually
just going to turn into a story about family.
But my favorite story is he got pushed in
school. He's two years old. He got pushed
in school and he turned around and looked
at the kid and got dead panned serious, "Don't
push Boone Macon." [laughter] So apparently
they wanted to make T-shirts out of it that
said "Don't Push Boone Macon." [laughter]
He's turned into Napoleon Dynamite at age
2. [laughter] The the point of that was these
people are enormously important to me. My
family is enormously important to me and I
have to stop and ask that question what do
I really want? What is it I want. More importantly
how is that going to impact my children. And
I have a tendency to think way over the horizon.
I started to ask that question, what's the
world going to be like in 20 years for them?
Is it going to look like it looks today? I
don't know. So this is an important question.
And since not everybody got a chance to go
through and do eulogy and epitaph exercise.
I want to do this exercise. I want everybody
to just close your eyes for a second. We're
just going to go through this and I'm going
to talk through a couple of thing. But I want
you to fast forward into the future a little
bit. And visualize that you're at a church
or you're at a cemetery. It looks like your
friends and family are gathered. You take
a closer look. It's actually your own funeral.
The question that I should ask yourself is,
"who steps forward?" Who's the first person
to speak? Is it your wife? Your girlfriend?
Your parents? Your children? What is it they're
going to say about you? What is it that you
want them to say? Now, hold on to that. Come
back just a little bit. When you're there,
you might have seen a grave stone. Might have
had your epitaph on it. What did you see?
You can open your eyes. I want to hear from
you guys. What did you see? Be completely
honest. Lived fully, loved openly. Who else?
I'll call on people. People who raised their
hand said that they got it. I'll call on you.
Who else? One more. C'mon. One more. [pause]
Awesome [laughing] Who had trouble seeing
anything? Yeah. Why do you think that is?
No sense of urgency? No sense of "hey, I've
got to pay attention to this?" It's an important
question to ask yourself. You have to stop
and think whether you are 55 or whether you're
20, what are people going to say about you?
Got to just -- it's a basic question that,
if you don't ask those kinds of questions
of yourself and they're simple questions,
but they're hard. They're really hard questions.
That's what's going to give you the power.
One of the things that we talk about at our
new venture is that we're about building the
individual before we build the business. And
that's one of the fundamental questions you've
got to ask yourself. What is it that you really
want? And doing an exercise like that brings
it into focus. You just sit down take an hour
or so to ask that kind of profound question
about where it is your life's going to be.
And it sounds morbid. But it's also deeply
freeing. So I did this exercise. And one of
the things that I read to my children. And
let's see if I can actually get it to work
out for me. But Oh the Places You'll Go. I
don't have it all here, but starts out with
congratulations. Today is your day. You're
off to great places. You're off in a way.
You have brains in your head. You have shoes
in your feet. And I can't see the rest. Hopefully
you get the gist of it. Is that you've got
an opportunity. You've got a grand journey
ahead of you. And asking that question, "what
do you really want?" Emphasizing those words.
I ask that question right after I left LiveStrong.
And I spent probably about two years trying
to explore some kind of way that I could shape
the future for my children. What is it going
to look like in 20 years and started talking
to as many people as I could talk to. And
I started thinking through all these ideas
of how we can create this social impact. And
how you can create this fancy ecosystem of
conscious consumers and social entrepreneurs.
And, you know, social venture capitalists
who are going to come together, "hey, this
is going to be a utopia." And it was ambitious
and probably substantially naīve. But I did
that. And it's the thinking of that that then
led me to a couple of folks who I met. Actually
friend of mine Ed Perry who then introduced
me to another guy, Jeff Sandefer. You guys
don't know Jeff, he is the founder of the
Acton Foundation for Entrepreneurial Excellence
here in Austin. They have the Acton MBA program
which if you haven't seen it you should check
it out. It's an amazing program. That's where
we spun off of. But as I was talking to these
guys and I was showing them this. They were
just kind of looking at me and being really
polite to me at the same time [chuckles] and
just kind of shaking their heads. My question
was like where am I going to fit in? I've
got this big grandiose. I've gone through
thinking what I want. How am I going to get
started? Where is that first step? And for
me, that first step actually became -- came
with thinking about the individual. And I
started thinking about it and this idea of
entrepreneurship -- not necessarily social
entrepreneurship, because that has a lot of
people fixated on what that means and trying
to define entrepreneurship. For me it started
looking like how can I start impacting the
lives of people who are entrepreneurs who
are going to be entrepreneurs and what is
it I could do to provide them something that's
going to accelerate where it is they're going
to be. They're not going to kind of meander
around. And as Jeff put it, they're not going
to make the same kind of mistakes. And so,
it starts with the individual. Building the
individual before building the business. And
then, the framework that we use and we think
about -- it's based on a framework that's
in the MBA program called a Life of Meaning.
And it's starting with the individual. What
is it that you really want? Then layering
in what are the people around you. So if you
think about on a day-to-day basis, who are
the people around you that are really most
important? And how do you do things to support
and empower one another? And then, finally,
how are you going to start creating some action
around that? What are those milestones? What
we do is we actually set it up so our program
goes through and you talk to people. This
is not a sales pitch. It's a good exercise
to start talking to people who are ten, 20,
30, 40 years older than you. Start trying
to understand where are they? What regrets
did they have? What did they do well? And
what is it that you want to do and where do
you want to be? Just asking yourself that
question, "who am I going to interview?" When
I started doing that, that's a hard question.
Because then I started saying, "I want to
interview this guy. I don't want to interview
that guy 'cause he's not in the industry.
Or I'll interview this guy but not that guy"
But you got to start. Time's precious. You
got to make sure that you don't waste the
opportunity you have. And you guys -- I mean,
obviously working at Google, you're enormously
intelligent individuals. Don't waste the time.
Ask yourself, "what is it that you really
want?" If you can ask yourself that fundamental
question, you start moving down the path of
getting to where you really want to be. So
apparently we've got questions. Oh, that was
a cheering ending wasn't it? [laughter] So
thanks.
>>Male Interviewer: Ooh, this is really loud.
Lower this. Better.
>> Randall: Oh, we're sitting in chairs.
>> Interviewer: Sure.
>> Randall: Are you Oprah or Phil Donahue.
>> Interviewer: Neither. You haven't my bank
account.
>> Interviewer: Okay, so if you still want
to submit questions on the DORY, it's go slash
Randall. We have some great questions here
so far. I can pull them up. [pause] Okay.
What are the top five mistakes that an entrepreneur
makes.
>> Randall: Top one? Not asking questions.
I think that that sounds my presentation solved
the question. I think it's a lot about trying
to figure out where you're going to be and
how you're going to get there. Making sure,
that if money is what you want, that's fine.
But be honest with yourself that's what you
want. But try and think about what are the
things I want to do. Where do I want to be
in my life. If you can start connecting what
you are passionate about. The idea of identifying
what's your calling. What is it that your
unique gifts are that you do better than anybody
else? Most passionate about. Then what's that
need in the world that you could fulfill?
If you could figure that, that's still. But
if you could figure the intersection of those,
that's something that becomes I think pretty
powerful. And you start being able to then
move forward in very deliberate way as opposed
to being driven by what investors say or what
employees say. And you start trying to give
yourself some kind of a compass that allows
you .
>> Interviewer: I do want to open it up because
I'm sure people have thought of questions.
But the next question is a good segue. That's
great, fine and dandy; you've figured out
what you want. But, what if, the window has
passed. So what about us old folks who are
old school and you have mortgages to pay and
children to feed. I can't just take that risk
and follow my dream. What advice would you
give then.
>> Randall: It goes back to just kind of explore.
I'm 40. So I qualify for the old school record
collection. And it's -- I don't think that
it's ever late. I mean, my dad who was Southern
Baptist preacher and now is an entrepreneur
himself. The cycle that he went through is,
he was in the military. He went and became
a preacher. They he went to a start up. Then
he went to Fidelity Investments. And he's
got his own thing that he started five, ten
years ago. I don't think it's ever too late.
I think it's about making sure where it is
that you want to be. If you can identify that,
then I don't think it's ever too late.
>> Interviewer: Any questions in the audience?
>>Male#1: If you use this mic, the we can
get it on the YouTube channel.
>> Male #2: Thanks. Are the kind of some of
the answers that you're figuring out now could
you come up to those answers without those
experiences you had as a 20 year old rock
climbing? Is that something, that if you had
asked those questions earlier, you would have
come to a different place?
>> Randall: Yeah, that's a good question.
I don't know. I think that when I look at
this -- because there are questions that are
still really valuable and important to me
as well. But I think it's about the intentionality.
Part of what our mission is that we really
want to inspire, equip, and connect purposeful
and passionate entrepreneurs. And you know,
I think you can get there. I mean, there's
tons of examples of people who have gotten
there without the questions. And it's not
like the questions are rocket science. But
it's a matter of just sitting down and having
a habit of asking yourself those questions.
And that becomes enormously valuable in and
of itself. Especially if you start asking
yourself those questions in connection with
other people that are either essential business
partners or close friends. You start thinking
about the quality that those relationships
start to change. And you start kind of asking
yourself the questions that maybe don't have
-- there isn't a real sense of urgency around
them. I mean, not everybody is Eugene O'Kelly.
But if you start spending some of that time,
it provides at least an accelerant. As one
of the guys who went through our program was
actually telling Dave, and I use because he's
our shining rock star. But he just opened
up a business down in Westgate that it's called
TreeHouse. You guys go check it out. Evan.
That's like free advertising here. But he
went through the program. This guy -- Rick
is smart. I look up to him in a lot of ways.
He was doing M and A, mergers and acquisitions,
at Citibank and he decided he was going to
go start something up. While he was raising
his series A, he decided to go through our
program because somebody recommended it. And
the way he described it was rocket fuel. And
I think that that's -- that's the way you've
got to view it. Whether it's our program or
something else. You got to ask yourself, "where's
that rocket fuel?" Where am I going to find
that material that's going to allow me to
get there faster and sooner. Does that answer
your question.
>> Female #1: What happens when you figure
out what you really want to do but it conflicts
what your friends and family want for you.
Do you pursue that and do you sacrifice those
relationships.
>> Randall: Wow. [laughing] I don't know.
That's a personal question. I think that you've
got to -- you've got to ask them -- those
folks -- what is it that they really want
for you. And if that's something that you're
passionate about -- I don't know. That's a
tough one. I've had the luxury of having highly
supportive people. But I think that it may
be a question of can you go and start seeing,
are there other people who share that same
kind of passion. And are there ways of cultivating
those kinds of relationships so that you can
really ferret that out. And, you know, understand
why is it that they don't want? Is it -- like,
my person who heads up my product department
decided to go to Kenya for the next two weeks.
Why is she going to do that? But it's a passion
of hers. I didn't want her to do that, but
it's something that she needed to do. All
cross our fingers she doesn't get killed.
Did that answer your question? Sorry.
>> Interviewer: I said something earlier.
I'm going to kind of mix something you said
with the question here. You said something
earlier about asking someone five years older
than you. Ten years older than you; twenty
years older, to see what they think. And I've
heard something similar to that where when
you were five, you're left to your own devices,
you will surely kill yourself. And ten years
later when you're 15, you ask yourself were
you an idiot when you were five, you say,
yes. But reality is at least half of the students
who make it to 15 the rest probably end up
killing themselves. 25 year, your target rate
gets a little better. But when you ask yourself
when you're 25 if you were an idiot when you
were 15. The answer is yes. So when you're
45, 55-year-old says "you're an idiot now".
>> Randall: [laughter] That's my operating
assumption on every. I don't have the answers.
That's a qualifier.
>> Interviewer: If you can look back on the
questions. What's been the most difficult
thing you learned throughout the time being
in your own start up. And the question I'd
add to that what do you think you're doing
now that might be a mistake.
>> Randall: Oh. I think that -- wow, when
I look back at the things that -- and the
startups that I worked at. I think there were
a lot of people who were really focused on
getting rich. And there is absolutely nothing
wrong with making money. Please, do not ever
interpret it that I think you should go into
poverty [chuckles] in order to really find
out what you want. But it ends up driving
a lot of decisions. Especially when you get
into a situation where, you know, when I was
working at a company that was public and it
was during the Internet start up. The decisions
became more about how do you make those quarterly
numbers and less about what's the long-term
value. And so, those decisions get truncated
and a lot of times they start making -- and
I'm guilty of this as well -- start making
decisions that are good for what's going to
happen in the next month but horrible for
what you're going to be doing in two, five,
ten years from now. And that's a big mistake.
I think the mistake in terms of what we're
doing right now is, I don't think you can
ever get enough of talking to your customers.
I think the thing that we're probably haven't
done an effective job yet is really understanding
them. The deep passionate needs of what our
customers want. I think we've got a little
bit and we've got people who are excited about
it, but we've got to have more. We've got
to connect with people. So if anybody wants
to participate with any research effort, I'll
sign you up.
>> Male #3: So what did you learn from working
with a guy like Lance Armstrong? And why did
you leave LiveStrong? I heard it's doing really
well.
>> Randall: I think one of the biggest values
of working with and around somebody like Lance
as well as a lot of the other folks at LiveStrong
is that there's a constant sense of dissatisfaction.
That you aren't doing enough, you can do more.
And that constantly pushes the boundaries.
And it's nice to have that. And also, in that
kind of business, there is a sense of urgency
because it is about people's lives. That becomes
poignant. I think the reason that I left the
LAF was I think it was more about when I started
asking myself the question, "what kind of
impact can I have?" And "am I able to still
contribute and make that impact at LiveStrong?"
Or "had I kind of contributed what I was going
to contribute?" And I think I contributed
what I was going to contribute to that. Could
I have stayed there longer? Probably. Could
I have done some other interesting things?
Without a doubt. But I think the stuff I'm
doing now energizes me as much if not more
to think about what is it that I can do to
impact and bring what I saw as urgency in
individuals who were cancer survivors, -- urgency
they had in their lives and try and kind of
create that urgency for individuals who are
entrepreneurs or becoming entrepreneurs. That
gets me up in the morning. Hey, 20 years from
now am I potentially going to be planting
a seed that my children are going to be able
to benefit from. That's what's driving me
more than anything.
>> Female #2: Okay. So I know a lot of us
here are recently college graduates. And some
people are further into their careers. But
if you were were where we are sitting now,
what would be the strongest advice you would
wish when you were here someone would give
you.
>> Randall: First of all, you're probably
light years ahead of where I was [chuckles]at
that point, because I was rock climbing. [laughter]
For people who know, rock climbers -- they're
not the most ambitious folks. Really fun to
hang out with. But that's a big question.
What's the biggest piece of advice? I think
it's don't be afraid to make mistakes. Take
risks. I was talking about my father and the
best piece of advice he's ever given me was
'life's forgiving'. And he's proof positive
of that. He restarted what he was doing in
his life so many times and he's doing great.
He loves what he's doing. And he's got a lot
to show for that. But it was being able to
take those risks. And I think you've got to
sit down and assess along with that is a question
of how well you can deal with ambiguity. You
probably deal with ambiguity a lot better
when you're younger. But I'm trying to understand
how comfortable are you being in a place where
nobody's telling you what you should be doing.
You've got to figure it out. And getting to
that point comfort with that kind of ambiguity.
Then I think you become, whether you're at
Google or you're somewhere starting your own,
you become a lot more powerful and focused
however you can make it in life. Whatever
it is.
>> Interviewer: Let's take a question on DORY
and then go back to the audience. You mentioned
something I really liked earlier. Building
the individual before you build business.
And so, this question is similar to that.
It says, "what attributes do you look for
in a partner? What're your feelings about
partnership versus going solo?"
>> Randall: Partnerships versus going solo.
It's funny. I actually asked that question
of somebody yesterday I was meeting with.
He said -- it becomes a question of -- with
a partnership how -- so part of what we do
is, when we're going out we try to identify
potential customers. we have kind of the direct
to consumer but then we're also partnering
with universities. And part of what we're
asking ourselves is do they share that philosophy?
If they don't care about the individual and
they don't really care about building that
individual, then that's probably not a good
partnership. And so, as long as it's something
that allows us to stay focused on what our
mission is and really creating those passionate
and purposeful entrepreneurs, then I think
we're more than open to that. But, if it's
not, then we have to probably take a pass.
And we've passed -- we've actually fired customers
because of that. It's a hard one.
>> Male #4: Well, I guess I have a 2-part
question. First one being I don't think, maybe
I just wasn't hearing well --. What is it
that you really want or are you still figuring
it out?
>> Randall: Yeah, I think what I really want
is a world for my children that isn't caught
up with the things that we're dealing with
right now. Like, European debt crisis. Or
a world where people on Wall Street are calling
each other and giggling about how they screwed
a grandmother out of her pension. And that
-- I mean, that's a big chunk of this new
venture is, you know, my bigger kind of 20-year
desire is I want to change the business culture.
I mean, I think Google does a good job of
doing that as well. We need, there needs to
be a systemic change how people think about
what they're doing in business and how it
impacts people. And that, you know, people
can define that as social entrepreneurship.
But I think that's just being a good person.
And so, that's what I would do.
>> Male #4: And I guess it helps if you said
you want to change the world for your kids.
But before you had kids, what you really wanted
would have been something else. You just changed
ten, 15 years down the line and you figure
you want something else, how do you deal with
that?
>> Randall: Part of when I was putting together
this presentation that was -- I started realizing
is that what I really want -- it's going to
change. Change is constant. You have to ask
yourself constantly, "am I doing what I really
want? And is it getting me to where I want
to be?" As long as I can continue to say,
"well, at the end of my life I want my children
to say that I was there for them and that
I did everything within my power to create
a better world for them." If they say that,
and what I'm doing today, I can kind of see
a line of sight and I think see milestones
getting to that, then I feel like I'm on the
right track. But yeah -- I mean having kids
provided a lot of clarity. I clearly didn't
have that in my 20s. [chuckles] Say, a good
chunk of my 30s as well. But yeah. It's a
hard question. It's a hard question.
>> Interviewer: We have another question here
from the moderator.
>> Interviewer: If you don't necessarily consider
yourself to be a Visionary entrepreneur, what
are some of the ways to try to get involved
with entrepreneurs to try to create a business
plan [inaudible].
>> Randall: Yeah, I think there's plenty of
-- I'm sure you guys know tech stars -- start
up weekend. All the seed accelerators that
are out there. Those seem to be like the low-hanging
fruit for everybody. And it's something we
really struggled with because it's a question
of, people can go there and get engaged and
have this really coding marathon and do some
pretty amazing stuff. But I think that when
you start trying to figure out what kind of
team -- something I definitely struggle with,
too, is trying to hire people is making sure
there's a shared passion and a shared vision.
And the way you can do that is by making sure
that you kind of ask those folks, partners,
team that you're working with, "hey, does
this all connect up with what everybody wants
longer term?" If everybody just wants to get
rich, great. But make sure everybody on the
team wants to get rich. Otherwise people are
going to get really annoyed and they're going
to walk away. You're going to have trouble
keeping people together. But if you can have
a shared vision of what that business is and
that connects with what people really want,
then I think that that becomes pretty powerful
way of approaching it. And I think that to
a certain extent the idea of being a visionary
that you have to be a visionary to be an entrepreneur
-- I don't subscribe to that. Because I'm
far from being a visionary. [chuckles] And
-- but I feel like that I can still classify
myself as an entrepreneur.
>> Interviewer: You mention something earlier
you were kind of showing [inaudible]. I'm
hearing that consistently from entrepreneurs.
They say as part of the ingredient of somebody
successful. You have to break it up in a pie
how much of it is luck, how much of it is
capital, how much of it [inaudible]-- what
would you break it into.
>> Randall: Wow. I'm not really good with
math. So I may not come up with 100 percent.
It may be a mis-shaped pie. [laughs] I think
that -- what were the options again? This
is like a math problem -- word problem.
>> Interviewer: Well, you can make up your
pieces -- luck, capital, being educated.
>> Randall: Oh I can make them up? I think
that a lot of it has to do -- there's timing.
I mean, people call it "luck," but I think
you make your own luck. You constantly are
trying to push forward. Like, the concept
model that I sketched up -- well, I think
people could say, "well, you're lucky that
you were introduced to Jeff Sandefer because
he's now funding this new venture that you're
doing." And my argument would be, "well, yeah,
but I spent three years." I mean, I did that
sketch in 2009. And I was thinking about it
for a good year, year and a half before that.
And it's -- you're going to create your own
luck. I think that that -- it's more about
putting some kind of stake in the ground and
moving forward. One of the concept you're
asking about -- like, this Idea of advice
being able to put that stake in the ground,
the sense of ambiguity. That's going to have
to change. And really saying, "okay, I'll
have to, you know, move when it comes there."
Like, a big part of it is just say, 50 percent
is, you know, having the right plan and team
in place. And 50 percent is being comfortable
with all that comes along with that. And with
all the people who tell you it's not going
to work. That you're too naīve. All the employees
that tell you that you're not doing the right
thing. That's always fun.
>> Male #5: What about the 'why' behind -- I
mean, I think it's such an important question
what do you really want. Breaking it out like
that is really powerful. What about the 'why'
that's behind that; how do you answer that?
And second, who is your mentor now? Who are
they and how important is that?
>> Randall: Yeah. Not sure clearly understand
so I'll try the why question. But I think
embedded in that question of what do you really
want, there is a why in that. Because if you
want -- if you want to be -- interesting we've
been doing, running ads. Doing AV Testing
on ads. And the people -- one of the things
we were testing -- we've got this message
of, "well, we can help you make money and
be a successful entrepreneur and we can also
help you discover what you're passionate about."
People want passion. So we started running
these ads. And one of the test ads was "discover
your real passion." Another one was "be a
millionaire by 30." And we had this simple
little quiz that we would send them to. Almost
everybody -- the vast majority of everybody
clicked on millionaire. But then the quiz
was actually broken down so that the output
would say, "well, you know, you really want
to kind of discover your passion." Or "no,
you're all about money." What was interesting,
everybody clicked on I want to be a millionaire
by 30 or 35 and then they answered this question
and 70 percent of them said, "I want to follow
my passion." And so, I think the why -- you
can say "I want to be a millionaire by 30,,"
but is that what you really want or is being
the master of your own destiny what you really
want. So peeling back those layers and getting
beyond the initial gut reaction is important.
What was the other question? There was another
one. Mentors -- yeah, I've got quite a few
people who I would consider my mentors. And
some of them are actually pretty close in
age to me, because they've done things that
I wish that I was skilled and talented enough
to be able to do. Evan is highly -- I don't
get a chance to talk to him as much, but he's
definitely. He's a mentor in the sense that
he's doing things that I wish I had the discipline
that he has. And there's other people who
are mentors -- I think a lot of the way I
look at it is, I can't find that one mentor
that does everything. And so, I end up trying
to take this design-thinking approach to mentors.
Where I'm going to get a multi-disciplined
panel of mentors. [chuckles] Get somebody
over here who's really focused in design and
design thinking. And somebody over here who's,
you know, really much more about the spiritual
aspects of it. Somebody over here who is a
lot more the nuts and bolts and gets it done.
And, you know -- yeah, I actually never really
thought of it that way, but that's kind of
the approach. I have a Frankenstein mentor
that I go to different parts of them [chuckles]
depending on what's going on.
>> Male #6: Do you have any advice for your
-- like about social entrepreneurs you work
with balancing what they want and then also
with the needs of the communities they're
working in. Like, concrete advice in terms
of how they can address those--.
>> Randall: When you talk about the communities
that they're working in what do you mean by
that.
>>Male #6: Well it seems like the social entrepreneurship
you're trying to have some impact on community,
right? What add And that's part of your goal.
So I mean what advice do you give your budding
social entrepreneurs in terms of finding how
to balance their needs and passions and finding
ways to fit the needs of the community.
>> Randall: Yeah, it's -- when probably about
a year ago we started going through the exercise
of -- the standard exercise of the mission,
vision, core values -- those kinds of questions.
And I totally got called to the carpet by
Jeff who's practically the chairman of my
organization. And he was like -- I started
I was putting in my grandiose " hey, I'm going
to create an ecosystem. I'm going to change
the world." And he's like, "yeah, that's cool.
That doesn't really talk about your customers."
And I think that that's the question. Because
I don't view us as trying to create social
entrepreneurs. We're trying to create some
kind of social impact per se. We want to have
an impact on individual's life and allow them
to define what it is they want to do. Everything
is, you know -- we don't profess to have any
kind of magical answer. And I think anybody
who does is probably lying to you. And so,
you've got to go back and make sure that what
you're doing, what you're passionate about
is actually connects with those people who
are your customers and that it's something
that they really both need and want. And there's
a delineation. That's one of the things we
struggled with was the need versus want question.
Do people want money or do they need, you
know, a mechanism that and frameworks that
allow them to become much more effective entrepreneurs.
>> Female #2: I have a question. What are
some of the books that have been Most influential
in your life in defining I guess both your
personal life as well as what you really want
and your passion.
>> Randall: I have to admit I am the slowest
reader in the world I'm pretty sure. I tried
to do the speed reading thing. It inhibits
my ability to get through a lot of books.
When you said that first one that jumped into
my mind was Jonathan Livingston's Seagull.
Short little powerful kind of inspirational
piece. I think that Letters to a Young Poet
is another one that I think has shaped the
way I think about a lot of things. And so,
that's kind of the touchy-feely side. The
one that actually kind of turned on the light
bulb for me which we use in our program is
called E-myth. It's by Michael Gerber. And
it talks about this idea of -- I don't want
to give it it away, but thinking about what
it is you -- what kind of entrepreneur you're
going to be. And making sure you don't put
yourself into a position where you are basically
in a self-employment trap. And so, it's -- I
think that one becomes like, "yeah, duh."
But sometimes it's like the really simple
things. [chuckles] "wow, probably should have
read that a long time ago.."
>> Interviewer: We're out of time, so we're
going to ask a question off the Dory. Since
I'm up here, I'm going to ad lib it a little
bit. You had mentioned the exercise and you
mentioned your goal was to make a better world
for your children. A lot of changes to that.
And so, it sounds like greed. And you also
mentioned bottom line. [inaudible] Effectively.
>> Randall: Now, I think I -- yeah, it gets
important to say -- and this is actually something
I've kind of come to a conclusion on over
the past probably year or two. I definitely
think was of this mind set of yeah social
entrepreneurship. Money shouldn't be your
bottom line. That's just not -- that's not
realistic. I think that it's important that,
if the idea of money being the only criteria
by which you measure success -- I think is
very risky. Because it's -- that's going to
drive -- that's going to become more important.
And then that then creates the incentive structure
for everybody in your entire organization.
We look at our core metrics or what we pay
attention to, is both sales -- because we
can't stick around. Otherwise, we're just
giving it away for free. We should just do
that. But sales are really important as well
as what's the experience that our customers
are having? How are they telling us it's good
or it sucks? And being able to understand
those pieces. So since our mission is about
really empowering those individuals, then
we have to use -- we have to balance those
things. It can't be one or the other.
>> Interviewer: Well, that was the question.
Because earlier you had also said that if
money was what you really want, then that's
OK [inaudible].
>> Randall: Sure, no -- I mean -- yeah, I
think that that -- and this is also important
is, this is my decision. This is the way that
I'm viewing it and that I -- my perspective.
But if you don't share that perspective, that's
completely legitimate. And I shouldn't -- I
think it's way arrogant for me or for anybody
else to say, "well, since you only value money,
you're a horrible person." That's not to say.
I think that -- if I implied that, then that's
wrong.
>> Interviewer: Well, we're out of time. Thank
you so much for.
>> Randall: Yeah, thanks, guys.
[Applause]